drea season two
season 42 survivor what pushed you to
audition
i was at a point in my career um where i
wanted to try something different i just
stole my business i just
basically gotten to
just like little
points where i was i wanted something
different and then
i said why not survive
weird but that's what i said and then i
applied it was the last day to apply i
applied thinking like there's no way
anyone's going to call me back and
they actually were crazy enough to call
me back so that's how i decided last
minute and it's a blessing everything
happens for a reason
so you apply knowing there are hundreds
of thousands of people who are also
applying you get that phone call what is
your reaction when you receive the phone
call to say you're going to be a cast
away on survivor
shock
you're shocked
and then i thought that they must have
called the wrong person
literally
i was like are you sure you want me
so yeah no it was it was shock and then
hyperventilation just like
shock
i don't know i don't know how to put it
i shock
pure shock
you must have had a great casting
audition video so
my question you grew up in texas but you
now reside in montreal are you
representing canada this season
i'm wrapping canada with the foundation
from san antonio
i
i'm trying to be politically correct
here i've lived in canada longer it's
the longest place i've ever lived now at
this point so
i know montreal montreal is my home
montreal's
who i relate to i am montreal so
definitely bringing the aspects of what
i've learned in my adulthood and how to
um
how to
deal with people and situations and all
the things like things that i've learned
actually in montreal so i would say i'm
repping canada in in the survivor and
everything that canada
has
taught me including
weather resilience
now you say you're repping canada which
means i'm sure you are aware the bar is
very high this season with erica last
season winning the title what kind of
pressure does erica's win for canada put
on you this season
i would say that even before erica won
canada
pressures you period on survivor like
[Laughter]
ken is hardcore like their hardcore
survivor fans like i know everyone who
anyone and everyone knows survivor in
canada they can name their favorite uh
castaways like it's a religion in canada
i always say that because uh that's how
my texans know that it's serious
survivor's religion in canada um so even
before erica like i knew that there was
going to be pressure because
it's real
it's real it's real israel and then when
erica won
there you should have
the messages are non-stop they're like
you have there's a bit of breakfast in
canada or you're going to get deported
literally so that's true we're coming
for you we don't take the title now
how did you prepare mentally physically
and emotionally for survival um
so
mentally
physically and emotionally those are
very good questions actually uh i train
actors to prepare for roles so
they're having to gain weight lose
weight or maintain or transition
throughout a world like so i'm very good
at that that's my niche so i knew going
in
um i hoped that i would lose a lot of
weight pregame i was like i want to
laugh but in order to laugh
i'm going to have to gain a lot of
muscle mass because i knew that
i'm used to eating a certain amount and
exercising so i
physically my preparation was muscle
mass
so it was an awkward moment there when
my clients would see their trainer
gaining weight
and they're like what's going on so that
was that for my physical aspect um
mentally i started uh
meditation really learning how to
meditate and how to center myself
that was very helpful for me
and then emotionally i would say that i
worked on my breath my breathing breath
work
so those three things were the things
that i really concentrated on pregame
gaining weight muscle mass meditation
and breath work
when in stressful situations
very interesting now something i found
particularly interesting in your bio is
you noted your pet peeve is dishonest
people yes the question is are you able
to see through someone when they are
lying yes
okay so my follow-up or the long longer
version of that question is are you able
to see through people when they are
lying and if so what are the tell-tale
signs
so
i'll answer why i put dishonesty it's
just because um i knew that
i when i answered that i'm true to
myself i just don't like dishonest
people but i know i'm playing a game of
where people will have to be dishonest
towards you but there's only so many
lies that people can tell before they
end up revealing themselves and i'm
really good at
catching people in those lives
i'm good at asking questions i'm good at
listening and i'm good at um
reading body language so i knew that
that would help me in this game because
as such a pet peeve of mine that i could
see
through someone's body language in their
mannerism if they're lying to me or not
because i can stay cool and collective
but other people are stressed out
so
it's true it's really weird
but i thrive in stressful situations
[Laughter]
well it seems like you've signed up for
the right show then um without giving
too much away how was your experience
playing survivor
different from obviously watching it at
home
it's real
it's really
really
really real and um
it's
life-changing and i know it's you you
hear people say this afterwards but if
you can last even one day on survivor it
will change your life um your
perspective
how you deal with people how you view
challenges um
and for me being in the game i realized
that like wow
this is more than just
a game this is
an inner challenge and i will forever be
different and i am
now my last question for you is if you
could sir if you could describe survivor
season 42 in three words
what would they be
oh
[Laughter]
challenging
um
[Music]
unpredictable
very unpredictable um and
the best it's probably gonna be one of
the best seasons people will watch
i'm sorry but it's the truth it's a good
one